[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein billig rezept und zwar
in form einer sonne gefühlt habe ich das
ganze mit spinat und etwas käse
die führung ist wirklich wunderbar wird
sich schmecken es auch sehr gut und ich
werde gleich aus einer portion zwei
sonnen zu bereiten
zwei songs sagt man das doch man sagt es
so wäre das einer passion zwei sondern
zu bereiten und die eine könnt ihr zum
beispiel also entweder habt ihr viele
gäste da oder er ist als auch viel und
könnt zwei auf einmal auf essen oder ihr
könnt einfach zwei zu bereiten und die
einen nur kurz vor backen einfrieren und
dann habt ihr einfach immer was war wenn
zum beispiel von teilnehmern vor der tür
stehen das ganze sieht wirklich
wunderbar aus und so einfach in der
herstellung dafür brauche ich aber erst
mal ein hefeteig und den bereit ich auf
diesen zutaten für den teig verwende ich
900 gramm mehl 150 gramm sonnenblumenöl
250 milliliter wasser 150 gramm
naturjoghurt da nämlich den 35
prozentigen einen teelöffel zucker einen
teelöffel salz und zehn gramm hefe
zuerst löse ich jetzt die hefe im wasser
auf und verteilt sie sich nämlich gut im
teig und jetzt gebe ich alle zutaten
hier in eine rührschüssel und kann den
teig dann gut durchkneten und entweder
macht ihr das jetzt mit der hand oder
mit der küchenmaschine ich mache so
immer ganz gerne weil ich ihnen gerne
sieben bis zehn minuten kneten lasso
wieder besonders schön und ansonsten
einfach lächerlich durchkneten
jetzt ist der tag wunderbar reich und
ich kann ihn hier herausnehmen und zu
einer kugel formen und ihnen dann gleich
aufgehen lassen
dabei spricht jetzt die arbeitsfläche so
ein bisschen mit wachstum spray ihr
könnt auch öl oder mehr verwenden
wenn auch die schüssel ein bisschen
fetten oder brillen mit sind teig zu
einer kugel formen und hineinlegen und
da kann ich den abgedeckt eine stunde
ruhen lassen und in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die füllung vorbereiten
für die füllung verwende ich 40
milliliter olivenöl 2 zwiebeln die habe
ich bereits geschält und gehackt zwei
esslöffel tomaten und paprika mark etwa
400 gramm käse und etwa 180 kommt
frischkäse ich habe ich einen teelöffel
chilli und jeweils einen halben
teelöffel salz und pfeffer und ein kilo
spinat stets zuerst das öl in einen
großen topf und jetzt wird auch ein
mittels großer topf für nötig wegen dem
spinat
ihr könnt jetzt die füllung so machen
wie ich oder zum beispiel auch fleisch
füllungen oder was mit champignons wird
auch ganz gut passen und ich kann jetzt
hier zuerst einmal die zwiebeln
rundherum anbraten riese schön classic
sind das heißt dauert etwa vier bis fünf
minuten und in der zwischenzeit ich habe
den spinat schon gewaschen kann ich den
spielarten bis ins schleudern dass er
einfach das wasser verliert
[Musik]
den spinat hier dazu geben wenn ein
bisschen großes können so ein bisschen
mit den händen zu rufen und das mache
ich jetzt auch mehreren etappen denn das
hilft nämlich viel aus aber das
spielfeld der gleich zusammen und wenn
wir dann noch ganz ganz wenig
[Musik]
jetzt ist die flüssigkeit fast verkocht
da kann ich jetzt noch tomaten und
paprika mark dazu geben und das paprika
markt das hole immer einen türkischen
supermarkt und es gibt es einmal im
charme von einmal in bild und da könnt
ihr einfach selber entscheiden ob es
eher schärfer oder minder haben möchtet
jetzt noch die gewürze dazu und dann
alles kurz berühren
jetzt kann ich dem herd ausschalten und
die masse abkühlen lassen und nach dem
abkühlen kommt ein erster käse und
frischkäse dazu
jetzt ist die spielart wasser abgekühlt
da kommt jetzt der käse dazu das ist ein
ganz normaler hirten käse und natürlich
geschmacklich perfekt da mit rein und da
wird jetzt so ein bisschen zerbröselt
hier gebe ich jetzt noch frischkäse mit
wasser und kann dann die füllung
verrühren
[Musik]
der hefeteig teile ich hier sind vier
portionen 1
ich mache nämlich zwei barrick sonnen
[Musik]
jetzt könnte die kurz zu einer kugel
formen und dann schön ausrollen
beim ausrollen verwende ich jetzt ein
bisschen mehl und wenn das ganze jetzt
rund ausrollen und zwar so etwa 30 bis
35 cm groß man müsste einfach schauen
was beim bak nicht ihr habt mich
dementsprechend groß oder klein könnte
davon ausrollen
einen tag habe ich jetzt auf meinen kopf
gezogen und dann nehme ich jetzt keine
dauer back folie da ich den vergleich
schneiden werde und auf der back folie
darf man nicht schneiden das nehme ich
die erfüllung und ein bisschen
komplizieren die mitte so als kleiner
hügel etwas so auch nicht so groß und
der rest kommt jetzt die ringförmig
außen rum
aber ich muss am rand und diesem platz
laufen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nehmen wir euch am besten ein schälchen
oder einem teller der ein bisschen
größer ist als das was ihr in der mitte
platziert habt dann hier auch ein
bisschen fest drücken jetzt nämlich in
der unterlage ich nehme zum torten
retter war ich doch schön drauf
schneiden kann und kann jetzt ein
scharfes messer verwenden okay da
nämlich kennt weiß ich habe eine chance
sein die gleiche aber vielleicht bald
vielleicht recht bald ein 2 und dann
könnt ihr das hier ein schneiden so
breit wie ihr gerne möchte ich mache das
immer ganz symmetrisch das heißt immer
noch auf der anderen seite erst mal so
ein kreuz
ungefragt jetzt drehe nämlich das ganze
jetzt auf mein backblech und dann werden
die teile jetzt umgedreht also dass die
füllung nach oben zeigt
[Musik]
so sieht schon mal richtig gut aus aber
damit dass barrick noch einen glanz
bekommt bestreite ich jetzt gleich noch
mitten im 1
und da kommt einfach noch ein esslöffel
joghurt mit dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
jetzt beide zeitig gestrichen und die
gebe ich jetzt bei mir im kalten
backofen so können sie einfach im
backofen noch ein bisschen aufgehen ich
stelle denn jetzt auch etwa 200 grad
ober unterhitze und dann brauchen sie
etwa 35 bis 40 minuten
wir können sie aber auch gerne vorher
aufgehen lassen und dann in den heißen
backofen schieben
[Musik]
so sieht jetzt die sonne aus und ich
habe ein bisschen abkühlen lassen
direkt aus dem ofen heraus ist natürlich
sehr heiß und dann könnt ihr im prinzip
sondern spitze nehmen und einfach
abzutun also das ganze eher als
fingerfood das in der mitte entweder
habt ihr ein und dirt und so durch die
mitte der sonne ist oder ihr schneidet
sie dann einfach durch und das ganze ist
echt super cremig und würzig mit spinat
finde ich sowieso immer ganz lecker und
falls ihr das rezept nach machen wollt
dann findet ihr es auf meinem blog this
blog de
da steht noch mal alles ganz genau für
euch ich finds ein ganz tolles rezept
für den ramadan auch weil man super
vorbereiten kann und am abend glaube ich
die gäste oder euch oder die familie
einfach schön begeistern kann also viel
spaß beim nachhaken und bis zum nächsten
mal tschüss jungs konnte probieren
[Musik]